Hello hello, welcome.
Welcome to the Enterprise You virtual event.
I am super excited to have you here.
Excited about all the amazing conversations that we're going to have today.
Now, before we begin, let me remind you of one thing.
We won't be recording today's session.
This is a safe space.
Here, there is no judgement, no repercussions,...
...only unconditional love.
Joining us today is a superwoman and an amazing visionary.
And when I say amazing, I mean it.
What's special about her is that she loves helping young adults just like you...
...to build your public speaking confidence.
She believes that the distance between you and everything you want...
...is only one communication away.
As you listen to her story, you'll notice the power in your own voice.
Today, she'll be sharing her top storytelling and pitching tips...
...to help you with your next business presentation or job interview.
Let's welcome Molly Harington.
Molly, it's so good to have you here.
Thank you so much for joining us!